hey we're rhettandlink we're about to do
the wired autocomplete interview
I've never googled myself yeah I don't
Google myself every 48 hours all right
are rhett and Link are rhettandlink
brothers no I mean we have a camaraderie
like brothers from different masses my
brother my brother link from a different
mother our rhettandlink a couple yeah we
are a lot like an old married couple
yeah we are an old married couple which
is the greatest form of couple right now
yeah are readily nice in real life
because we seem nice on the internet we
probably don't have enough nicest I
wouldn't say that I'm especially warm
he's not there's only one way to find
out if we're nice in real life don't
meet us just google it our rhettandlink
actually friends it was a good stint
there where we were actually friends
yeah yeah yeah you know I'd say from
third until sixth grade right and then
middle school hit I got interested in
women and ever since then it's basically
just been for entertainment purposes
only all right more googling has been
done are rhett and Link still making
videos you know what you could have just
googled rhett and Link and you would
have seen that yes we are still making
videos our rhettandlink stoners ah no
our Retton link furries there's no easy
answer to this guy I think we did this
to ourselves when we saw a herd of
furries in Australia and then suddenly
started taking pictures with them I love
furries alright I am a furry are rhett
and Link fighting not currently but I I
think that's what people are wondering
like there's like it's kind of like
people think we're fighting I don't
think heinessen about our relationship I
think they're wondering if we're gonna
stage like a big pay-per-view fight like
ksi and Logan Paul and the answer is yes
and here we go
can rhettandlink oh we're getting to two
abilities can rhett and Link actually
sing
[Music]
we can sing a little we sing a little
what if what instruments can
rhettandlink play why don't we start
with you I can play the recorder at a
middle school level oh he can play as
the guitar well I'm pretty sure I can
play the recorder as well because I
think everyone can rhettandlink can you
eat that so someone is googling as if
they are sending us a message like they
think that Google is the direct mode so
your indication they're going to see it
with us honestly I think what's
happening here is they're trying to find
a song are you gonna eat that the answer
is yes we can't eat this I might throw
it up we won't have to work it depends
on what you mean by eating if placing in
your mouth is eating yes we get that far
a lot rhett and Link can you smell fear
we have a video whose title is can you
smell fear
oh it is don't you remember when I got
up on the ladder and you got into a vat
of snakes or something then we smelled
each other's underarms oh yeah
to see if we could smell the fear and we
couldn't yeah I'm I'm I'm smelling a lot
of fear right now that this is that
we're gonna look stupid I don't even
have a fear about that anymore I just
embrace it
why rhett and Link
why do rhett and Link save Tokyo I say
the T word I'm not gonna say it now
because if I did save the T word then
rut would have to say what for a long
time so I'm not gonna say the T word why
do rhett and Link homeschool we
homeschool because the public education
system is a liberal conspiracy to
brainwash children into believing things
like global warming is real
we don't homeschool anymore oh yeah I
forgot we don't homeschool anymore we
our kids are in the public school system
being brainwashed
why did rhett and Link move to
California we wanted to make our show
commercial Kings on IFC and we needed
the release we needed to be present for
it yeah I need to be actually in the
show which was based in Los Angeles
why did rhett and Link stop here
your biscuits is our weekly audio
podcast within also a week later comes
out in video form on our YouTube channel
and if I'm not mistaken it didn't stop
we're still doing it if you just google
to ear biscuits the latest episode will
pop up have you ever put butter in your
ears
do rhett and Link have jobs do they have
real jobs is that is the real question
it's great to be able to say no we don't
have jobs yeah that's right
do you rhett and Link curse hell no no
do you rhett and Link have tattoos yes I
have links wife's name tattooed on my
butt and I also have my wife's name
tattooed on my butt do you reckon like
live together not anymore not anymore we
have made that mistake for our entire
college career okay did rhett and Link
past-tense go to college oh yeah we did
we went to college so hard that we came
out with engineering degrees yeah a lot
of good that does we use it every day
did rhett and Link get a vasectomy like
corporately well we both got vasectomies
we multiple each Laurel each man got his
own vasectomy same doctor and there was
a camera President did rhett and Link
find miss Locklear Locklear is our first
grade teacher
we made a documentary about looking for
her but if we told you the answer to
this we'd be spoiling the movie that is
over ten years old ten years old we
found her how did rhett and Link become
friends oh well right alongside them
miss Locklear question their first grade
class held in from recess for writing
profanity on her desk mm-hmm I wrote
Helen link wrote balls apparently Tyra
damn how did rhett and Link meet Stevie
Stevie is our right hand woman let's
reenact it the real answer is TV come
out you come out here can you stand
stand here this is where you're gonna be
working Stevie basically
we're gonna make a show and then just go
you're hired
produce stuff there's a little that's
how it was
we're rhettandlink oh we're - rhett and
Link live well link let's be worrying
about this hey three just be Jenner
general turn Green Valley Street in
Tarzana California never been there we
live in in a constant state of seeking
self validation through the internet
that's where we live yep we reside there
where our rhettandlink from I'm from
Harnett County North Carolina y'all come
see us well so am i but now I say from
Los Angeles but originally from North
Carolina but before that Georgia where
is Rhett and Link's studio it said one
set let's be vague about this
we work in an existential place of
friendship and happiness
that's our studio okay Google is a
powerful tool unless you use it to
Google things about us yeah a lot of
dead ends there